واسطه جنازات انه شطاء ومراسم تشييعهم
والخارجين على حمله القمع في العصيان
اجتماعيا وثقيا يقوده جيل جديد تقف ايران
امام موجه احتجاجا الثانيه تستندوه من
الرصاص الحيه والضرب بالهراوات قوه رفضا
واصرار على السير خارج جمهوريه الخميني
وربما عليها
[موسيقى]
اذا وكما تابعنا لم يعد التلويح بالحرس
الثوري راديعا ومات شعار الموت للديكتاتور
تقليدا ملازما للتظاهرات يستهدف المرشد
معنويا والاهم بشكل مباشر لكن الليل
لانظمه الشموليه في الازمات الداخليه
تجنبها الاجابه على الاسئله الملحه واحد
على الوجديه الشعر جاهز وان لم يعد رن رن
انه الشيطان الاكبر امريكا التي يتهمها
المرشد الايراني
مجددا بالمناسبه قاسم سليماني في ربطه
الاحتجاجات بامريكا لكن كلاهما تحرق
صورهما وبشكل يومي من شده الغضب اطلق
عليها النار هذه المراه
[تصفيق]
لكن سؤال لا مشروع ايضا من اين يخرج
المتظاهرون ومن هم وماذا يريدون ومن هو
عدوهم او خ
صمه يخرجون من شوارع المدن الايرانيه ومن
مدارسها ومن جامعاتها يريدون الحريه خصمهم
داخلي ولا تعنيهم ذكرى اختي حامل السفاره
الامريكيه لا من قريب ولا من بعيد